hey guys matt here from codetech
controllers just want to talk to you
quick about
shared pointer and
uh let's say the downside of shared
pointers or the risk or the thing you
got to watch out for with shared
pointers and this is something i ran
into a little bit while developing my
game engine and using them and once i
was writing a bunch of tests a couple
issues with how i was using shared
pointers popped up and i just kind of
want to go over that so people are aware
of it and that you can learn for it so
i'm just going to tack this on to my a
memory management series and hopefully
people can get something out of it now
the crux of the problem here
that happens is well
when you get another reference to the
shared pointer it increments
the count the use count and as long as
use count is not zero
this continues to exist in memory so
what this means is that if you're
sharing these out like if you want a
bunch of different things to have access
to an object
then
you gotta really think about the
lifetime of things because sometimes
something might still have it
when the true owner
should or goes out of scope or something
but this piece of memory still exists
and then when you re-implement the
object
something weird happens because it still
exists and you end up trying to make
another one and then it's like you get
some odd happenings with things living
longer
i don't know if that makes a whole lot
of sense but basically the way around
that is to uh get a weak pointer so if
you get a weak pointer out of the shared
pointer the weak pointer doesn't keep it
alive
the weak pointer needs to be cast to a
shared pointer
before use so when you cast the weak
pointer to a shared pointer that checks
if it's still alive so that's how you
can do it if you don't want
it's existing in memory to necessarily
keep the life cycle going maybe you want
access to something that's a shared
pointer and
sometimes you want to increment that use
count
other times you just want a reference to
it as a weak pointer so that if the main
thing goes out of scope then uh your
weak pointer will just fail to cast
as it's no longer there that all
probably sounds really complicated so
let me show you a little example
okay so i was running into some issues
with my
the lifetime of these
and i'm still fixing a few more but now
that i've narrowed it down i thought i'd
just make a quick video on it
so
some of the uh problems i was having
were related to how my
my camera was working so i used to have
a
it camera where you could get any camera
that currently exists in the game engine
by its unique id
and this used to return a shared pointer
and this was causing some issues
when i shut down the engine and then
start a new instance because it does
have a soft reset feature you can
essentially reset the whole thing but
not necessarily shut off the program
just gives it a fresh start and
even if you just close it but you don't
necessarily have your main interface
variable go out of scope or destroyed
then anything you grabbed a shared
pointer with
like my old version of skit camera would
still continue to exist and cause some
strange issues i have the same problem
with uh see get window where you can get
different actual windows because you
know this can run multiple windows you
can have multiple windows open so you
can get them
that feature is not fully implemented
basically if you want to operate
functions on the window or the camera
you need to get access to it first
and with this wake pointer version now
these references won't keep it alive
basically anything that's a shared
pointer i have to carefully analyze for
these soft resets
that i'm doing in this particular
case in your case might be different but
you just gotta think do you want this
thing to continue to exist if you get
access to it a lot of these probably
don't need to be shared pointers at all
maybe some of them should be unique
pointers and uh something like that or
maybe they should be
the accessors to them these are all
private here so you can't necessarily
access the the accessors to them should
probably be mostly weak pointers and
when you use a weak pointer i'll just
show you an example here let me take a
look at my fly controls because these
were kind of bugged with uh shared
pointers for a while because one of the
things
this my little fly control setup this
basically just uh
just sets up some functions within the
engine kind of like a little helper
thing so i don't have to retype it every
time i want flight controls i can just
call this function but basically one of
the problems i was having was any time i
would call this get window
it would create another shared pointer
and if i did it in the wrong place
it could
cause it to just exist even when i shut
down everything so instead now as you
saw get window now returns a weak
pointer and there it is it's uh well i
have it declared globally and locally
only to this file because this is just
you know self-contained vial
so now we get a shared pointer called
fly window and you can't use this
directly you can't really do anything
with a weak pointer except one thing
basically well there might be more but
there's one main thing you do and you
call
dot lock on it and
set it equal to a shared pointer of that
type so you have a sharepoint of the
window i'm just calling a local fly
window and call flywindow.lock and then
i can operate on this shared one
this will all just fail miserably if
this weak pointer doesn't exist so
but this is now safe because as you can
see this is within an if block
and this is a lambda that's going to
operate once every loop basically or
anytime you click a mouse button and now
what it does is it
only gets a local
uh shared pointer now this isn't
actually an egregious example because
this one in particular wasn't causing
problems when it was just
directly casting to a shared
since it goes out of scope right here
anyway
and uh it was just disappearing right
away but there were some other ones that
were causing problems in other places
but basically that's how you use it if
you're getting a weak pointer i mean
let's just look at this kit this just
returns
says it just returns in window right and
window is actually a shared pointer
but we're returning it as a weak pointer
of the window so that's handling all of
that
and this is the weak pointer so that's
basically how you use it right there you
just cast it to a shared pointer
before you actually use it
and that cast will take care of
everything and you want to have this
locally within your block go out of
scope
very quickly so you might have this this
whole setup something like this within a
function that gets called every once in
a while but destroys once it's done
oh
well uh there might be a better example
somewhere let me look at one of my tests
here yeah let's look at this model test
here because it does a very similar
thing so we init the engine sure that's
all fine good and then we want to make a
camera that stays the screen size
because you can do all kinds of stuff
cameras so we want to get a reference to
the camera this is a weak
pointer or weak reference so
and this is global so this is where i
was running some of these problems so i
have it actually declared up here
there's these weak references
but so if the engine shuts down these
weak pointers won't keep these
references alive and we'll keep the
memory alive that's the whole point
because we want to reuse those for every
test basically
in this case at least you might not
always want to do that but
uh just depends what you're doing but
i'm basically running up in this
particular example i'm running
a bunch of tests in a row you know soft
reset the engine start it up test
something else soft reset start it up
and i'm just making sure all the memory
clears because
if it's an engine that runs on something
you want to be able to reset and clear
properly so that's basically what i'm
emulating with these tests so it's kind
of a specific example that might be very
different compared to what you're doing
but i digress and i'll continue so
we get this week reference so what we
got to do before we use it is lock that
weak reference
cast it to a shared pointer and you
might also notice that i have this
scoped within these blocks that's
because at the end of this we're all
done with all this stuff
and we want these shared pointers to go
out of scope these local refs but we
need to do this cast before we use them
because we're going to use them here see
when i
add a camera this uh interface is the
global it's the interface to the engine
basically when we add a camera we want
to set the camera size
to the window width and height so that's
why we want a reference to the window
and so we can get its width and height
it's just the way the engine is sure i
could abstract it further and make these
functions hidden away more but
i just decided to do a lot of things in
a way where it can actually have access
to some of the individual objects
and then select with the window you can
get the window and you can access all
its public functions same with the
camera get the camera and you can
actually solve public functions that's
just how this engine is uh progressing
and how it's being refactored as we go
still got a lot of work to do and i'm
working on it most days and you know
it's kind of the same with the camera so
we get the camera ref
it's a weak graph we hover over this and
it's not going to show
[Music]
yeah it gets a week ref to that one of
that so this is a weak ref
to actually use it you gotta call this
lock function on it and make a local
variable
and then i just want to call this
function on it keep camera window size
true that just means when you resize the
window camera resize along with it
typically you want that if you got a
camera set to your full screen
but this supports multiple cameras so
you might want a camera that you know
does specific things when you resize and
you can set that up too because you
might have like a uh rear view mirror
type of camera or something you know so
multiple cameras do work in this engine
currently
and we got a field of view thing you can
set on your camera too and then the
setup flight controls we already looked
at that function but basically it wants
a valid camera id uh from this ad camera
to set up on
and uh yeah you wanna
well there's a lot more going on here i
think that about covers it
so i hope that uh clears up a little a
few things about shared pointers if
you're a little unsure of how to manage
with them and uh kind of the point of
weak pointers and how to uh
not start leaking with shared pointers
and uh let me know if you have questions
i'll try to go into some more details or
maybe get better examples if it's
not super clear or if it's or if i'm
just making it more confusing but also
uh
yeah i guess that'll that'll do all
right peace out guys